as head coach of the Vegas Golden Nights a
franchise who won their first cup in only
their sixth year of existence for all draft
pick by the Detroit Red Wings di with the
sharks as a free agent as zand has it sends
it to the middle and a touch pass again for
sadena that just missed that's twice now the
sharks have had good looks in the mids slot
thrun and now bordalo to the net and a rebound
chance in front for Zaden and Thompson made a
big save drawing into the lineup as well as he
was recalled from the Henderson silver nights
due to the injury to will k a in game
one a shot and a goal by Michael amario
and Vegas after killing the power play
by the Sharks takes a one- nothing lead
and we're going to see him drive to the net right
here there's the defenseman as he skates in there
and's pinned up against the the post there as
Burl is just trying to get him out of there
and then amodio's got the time and space to to
make a nice shot here as it was a terrific pass
by William Carlson if anything it makks the
opening day roster out there wearing number
three for the Sharks on the F with the veteran
Yan Ruda here's a bouncing Puck to Zaden he
[Applause] scor Philip sedena
scores his first goal as a San Jose
Shark the things we're seeing the the defense
for the Sharks this pre-season and now continuing
tonight is right there that's just a simple play
off a hurdle but throws it by the forer coming
out at thr he just gets it by him down towards the
body of hurle comes right out to Zena looks like
he wanted to pass and then just turns and fires
finds a short side and all the way back to Mario
Ferraro 1-1 the score final seconds here of the
opening period a chance for marches so saved by
coo kinan that's a great pass saved by coo on
fire in the playoffs as takes a look looks like
he's going to pull the forehand wrist shot turns
a spinorama and coo K in not only does he make
that right pad stop look at the rebound control
right there Scoops it up gets the whistle before
marches so can get to the rebound and I was really
impressed with him in the preseason he adds a lot
of energy with that hurdle and Hoffman line and
you can see that he can be physical but he can
also add a little bit of skill and we saw that on
that play Zena as hurdle is of course a native of
the Czech Republic skating on a line together
here tonight in the first game of this 2324
season here is hurdle tried to get it through to
the net now knocked back in his Direction given a
shove by McNab but he works it to the point a shot
blocked in front by Braden McNab Ferraro keeps it
alive down to Zaden over to hurdle now toos hurdle
working against barbashev finds Burrows open Mario
Ferraro with the lane it's tipped and off the
pad of L Thompson as Hoffman tries to drive it
to the net start and I'd say at least through
the first two periods Hos look solid really
solid Maro turns fires that's blocked by hurdle
marcheso able to get it first and barbashev now
to eel eel skates away from Burrows the transel
at the line H scores Nick H on a one-time and
it's 2-1 Vegas line with eichel marcheso and
barbashev they get the offensive zone start
they win the draw and they keep it alive and
this is just a shot from that angle and you
can see just underneath the arm of kopo kinan
here as hay gets that Rolling Puck or actually
five hole there here's Stern now sand TR to get
inside and C rard over to the other side for
then he'll clear to Center as we're inside the
final minute here's Nick W his wrist shot and
he scored two quick goals for Vegas and all
of a sudden they open it up it's [Applause]
3-1 I think it's come a long way in the last
year with Vegas and showed it in the playoffs
and was another guy just a fourth line player but
exploded in the playoffs and in end of the regular
season here he finds some daylight and a step on
thrund and and just goes up and over the shoulder
a perfectly placed Shot Bar down so heg with
a two-point night and somehow the Sharks going
to have to find a way to rebound after that short
little tough stretch in Vegas when heg scores they
call it a Hager bomb and that was one of those
he got all of that one to beat too King in five
hle as we're underway here in the third period 31
Vegas as the Knights attempt to break out to a two
and0 record to start their season and getting off
to a good start last year was huge for them Vegas
started last season winning 11 of their first 13
games piled up a lot of points Luke cunan looking
for eckan behind the net relay to the point
blassic effort is blocked Theodore will send it
ahead and now Jack eel who leads all skaters with
five shots on goal in this game he has an assist
on one of the three Vegas goals tonight now Ben
Hutton he'll bounce it around to the other side
ronb there and losing the puck but it comes
back to cter he'll turn and fire and it's off
Escape now Stone as the Sharks getting sloppy
and he put it off the post William Carlson two
goals in 53 seconds late in that second period
is the difference in this one now here's pahal
scores brayen pahal with his first
National Hockey League goal and it's
41 mentioned being sloppy In Their Own Zone and
little more direct for the Sharks right there
that puck gets through baronov and Mar's been
really quiet for me tonight he hasn't really
touched the puck that much hasn't done much burls
tries to go out and block this shot through all
that traffic T League puck drops on her season
in January looking forward to that the Sharks
and their significant others taking care of a
lot of business in the off season but that's
the way you got to plan it right you do in the
off [Applause] seon how many children of NHL
players were born between June and September
probably most here's CER back for McNab he'll
reach back and that one blocked by zland it
stung him a bit javanni Smith tracks it down
here's hurdle hurdled in against Stone hurdle
to the net and his back hand goes wide off
followed by zedin and that's stopped by Thompson
nice attack there by tomash hurdle really nice
attack here's Ferraro he's got Burrows and now
sterm and that ramps off P stick High there's
a six fo6 egg recovering with the long stick stur
gets a body on Stone the puck to the point here's
feraro over to Sturm Nico for burrow teas
it up and that one blocked by Thompson that
might have hit his [Applause] helmet here's
ha again he's been a Workhorse at both ends
of the ice for Bruce Cassidy tonight Nicholas
H with a goal and an assist for Vegas in this
4-1 lead just over six to play here in the
third David Quinn light lit a fire under his
team here a much different effort right now
going on with the sharks Ecklund drve takes
it back one last time driving it in and that
will do it here for the 23 24 season opener